if you diet you lose weight the number
one cause of obesity is genetics that
means if you are born to parents that
have obesity you have a 50 to 85 percent
likelihood of having the disease
yourself even with optimal diet exercise
sleep management Stress Management so
when people see families that have
obesity the assumption is what are they
feeding those kids yeah they're doing
something wrong I've always heard that
it's the fast food that it's the Diet
Cokes that kind of thing that is the
instigator is that true how dare you
actually do you know this 79 to 90
percent of physicians in the United
States have significant bias towards
individuals that are happy are you
saying that doctors don't understand
obesity doctors doctors do not
understand obesity they want you to
think you have no capacity over your own
life